では よろしくお願いします
90番からお願いします
今日は第7章で 第7章っていうのは
この阿羅漢と分かっているんですね
いわゆる阿羅漢 阿羅漢という言葉
たまたま使っているだけのことで
あまりこの経典の この何といいますか
このチャプターね 章の名前
それほど気にしなくてもいいんです
で そんなにこの俗世間のことについては
仏教はあんまりそんなに真剣じゃないんですね
かなりふざけて冗談で使ったりする場合もあります
ただ 人々にとっては 物事をチャプターに分けて本に分けちゃった方がいいんですけど
お坊さんたちにとってはそんなのどうでもいいで
必要な内容であるということでね
内容はちゃんと覚えておかなくちゃいけない
それはちゃんと注釈を覚えておかなくちゃいけないし
それはしっかりやりますけど
ちょっと覚えやすいためにということでグループに入れてあって
それなりの適当な名前を付けてはあります
たまたまタイトルが合っている場合もあるし
合ってない場合もあります
それで 1番目 いくらかこの 7章目はいくらか内容難しいとはされてはいます
ガタッディノヴィッソカッサヴィッパムッタッササンバディサッバガンタッパヒナッサパリラーホーナヴィッジャティという 1番目ですね
ガタッディノっていうのは意味はないね
えーと まあガタッディナっていうのも旅を終わりましたというね
旅は終わりましたと それからヴィッソカッサっていうのは
憂悲の趣味を乗り越えているんだと
サッバディ すべての側面から
ヴィッパムッタッサ 解脱に自由になっている
サッバガンタッパヒナッサ
すべてのガンタっていうのは束縛
結びですね すべての結び
束縛から離れていて パリラーホーっていうのは
何でしたっけね 悩みですね
心の中でいろいろあれやこれやとかね
燃えている状態なんですね
焼けて焼いている状態なんですね
これ 心の中ではそういう状態はないんだと
だから文章としては この旅を終わって
旅を終了して 憂いをなくして
すべての束縛から自由になった人にとっては
それからすべての束縛を全部カットして自由になった人にとっては
心の もう どうしようかとかね
心配だとかね そういうこのパリラーが
この燃える状況っていうのは
バーニングですね バーニングでわからない
バーニング 状態で それはないんだと
まあだからそれだけでいいですから
それでいきましょう はい
旅を終わったということはどういう意味でしょうか
ガタッディナ 旅は終わるのはね
まあ目的に達したならばなんですね
そこで仏教では人生は旅ということにしてますから
生きることは旅なんですね
ずっと必死では生きていますね
なんかなかなか目的にはまだ達していないんですね
で 目的に達していないんだか
ないかということはよくわかるんですよ
あの 誰でもわかっています
まだ目的に達していないと
どういうふうにわかるかというと
人に聞いてみてください
あなた死にたいんですかと
で で 死にたいんですかと聞かれたら
日本人には聞かない方がいいんですね
嘘以外何も言う方法を知らないんだからね
まあ普通正直に語る人だったら
まあ本当はそのつもりはないんですね
死にたいというつもりはないんです
だから死にたくている人であってもね
自殺する人であっても
死にたくはないんです
で 安楽死させてくださいという人々にしたっても
他取る措置がないんだから
じゃあこうさせてくださいと言うんであってね
なんてありがたいことですかとね
やっぱり死にたいんだという気持ちは誰にもないんですね
待って それを待っている
期待して首を長くして待ってるということはないんですね
死を それでわかりますね
で まだ生きていきたいということですからね
まだ旅をしたいんですね
ということは まあ目的に達していないんです
だから生き 生きることが旅です
まだ終わってない さらに進めなくちゃいけないんです
それは自分の心でわかるんですね
もっと生きていなくちゃいけないということは
もう普通の人間ならわかってます
動物さえもわかってるんです
それぐらいは 旅が終わってないんだと
それで ただね ただ この今世の人生だけ旅というふうにはしません
輪廻ということが旅なんですね
[笑い]いわゆる輪廻っていうのは
まあ死んでからまた再生してしまうというね
で 壊れと壊れるものっていうのは
なんらかの形で再生するという
現代人は認めない思考なんですけど
まあ一応仏教昔からね
まあものは壊れますけど
また再生すると この再生という言葉
仏教は使いませんが まあもう適当な言葉もないんです
あの 適当な言葉 日本語に直訳したっても再生になりますからね
どうにもならんですよ
だから再有なんです 生じゃないんです
もう再有という言葉ないんだからね
で あの壊れたものはまあ再生すると言ったらありがたい話でしょ
壊れた壺がまた再生してまた壺に戻ったらもう全然悪くないんです
そんな夢物語は現実的じゃないんですね
だからそこは理解してほしいんですよ
壊れた壺が何かになるんであって
壺にはならないんです
だから壊れた壺が無にはなりません
再有にはなりますけど
それが別にありがたくなんともないんです
で そこで壊れた壺の破片を粉にして何か作ったりしたっても
誰か言ってくれなかったら
これはあの壺の破片で作った再生したものだと言わない限りはわかりませんね
だから後は追っていってもわからないんです
で まあ一応紙とか何とか買ったりする場合は
まあ皆さんは知らないかもしれませんだけど
高いものを買うんだから
私なんか選んで選んで安いものを買いますから
やっぱり紙はあのパックを買ってみたら
やっぱりこれは再生紙であると
再紙であるとあったらありがたいんだけど
やっぱり再生紙というふうに書いているんですね
いわゆる捨てた みんな各家から捨てた紙
いろんなものをまた再生して再生紙作ってるんですね
じゃあ分かりますかね
それ見たら ああ これ あの
何て言いますか 日経新聞の一部入ってるだとか
それはさっぱりわからないんですよ
どう追ってみてもわからないんです
しかし この厳密に調べるならば
あの 例えばDNAあれやこれやとかね
紙にはDNAはないでしょうね
わからない  そういう風に追っていくと
ああ あの日経新聞のDNAも一部入ってるんだというふうに発見することはできますけど
だから後を追っていくならば
そういう感じで追っていかなくちゃいけないので難しいんです
ただ見て ああ これはもうこのこの紙の再生紙であるとは言えません
そこで我々は再生紙 紙を使って使ってから
それでまるっきり無になるかというと
そうではないんですね
また再び何かになってしまうんですね
そういうのはもうあんまりにもシンプルだからね
まあ現代ではね そんなに面白い話ではないかもしれませんだけど
まあ昔はまあお釈迦様あの時代でも
これは大事なポイントとして見ていたんですね
もう物事はいつでも壊れる
壊れる 壊れる 壊れる これキリがなく壊れっぱなしなんですね
で 壊れっぱなしっていうことは同時に現れるですよ
だから現れなかったらどうやって壊れるんですかね
一回っきり壊れたら終わるんだから
だから普通見たっても
もの壊れるは壊れる いろんな物事壊れるんだけど
そこは別な同じなもので置き換えていくんですね
だから庭の雑草を取っても取っても取っても取って
またまたまたまた度々雑草が現れてくるんだけど
同じものじゃないんです
昨日取って燃やした雑草は今日また再び再生していますよということではないんだ
だから再有なんです で
生命にしても 死にたいのかと聞いたら
もう正直にちょっと待ってくださいと
いう気分になるんです
何かあるんですね やらなくちゃいけないことは
ということは まだ旅の目的に達していないんです
途中なんですね だから
この途中という気持ちがあるんだから
我々は必死になって生きているんです
それで 死んだということは
ただ単に体が機能停止したという肉体がね
肉体が機能停止したというだけの話で
生命として停止したという意味じゃないんです
生命として 命としては
もうちょっと待ってくれという状態でいるんだからね
やることはまだあるんですね
だからそのエネルギーはまた再生するんです
再有になるんです なって
また続けてみて また壊れて壊れていって
また死ぬところになってくると
やっぱりちょっと待ってくれという
そういう風に輪廻転生ということでね
まあ終わり 旅がずっと続けるんですね
その旅を続ける間では
もういいやと もう死んだってもう大丈夫だということになったら
もう再生しないんです
再生 再有はなくなるんですね
だから目的に達していないならば
もうやっぱり旅は続きます
旅を続きますというか
旅を進まなくてはいけないということになってますからね
一時的にでも停止することはできないんです
ずっと生き続けていかなくちゃいけないんです
自分で好んで自分で頑張ってきてるならば
そんなにストレスもかからないし
嫌でもないんです これ
かなり脅迫的に生かされているんですね
もう旅をしなくてはいけないんです
だから生きるということ自体もかなり負担なんです
誰にしても 楽しくてしょうがないということにならないんです
で 公園の雑を 雑草を取って
ゴミを拾ってきれいにするということは
自分が勝手にやっているならば楽しいんです
じゃあ五時半 五時に起きて
ここら辺を綺麗にしようかなと
ここら辺でも大体みんな五時
五時半あたりで起きて全部綺麗にしますからね
周りの人々は で 何も組織も何もないみたいです
何人かがなんかもう毎日やってる仕事なんで
結構みんな楽しくやってるんです
色々お互いに話をしたりとかで
朝早くもう私もそこら辺いたらもうちょっとみんな挨拶したりとか
結構元気で楽しくやってるんですね
なぜかというと 自分で決めてやってるんだからなんです
そこはここら辺のこの一丁目の誰かがね
みんなにあのポストに紙を入れて
もう分担ですか 分配決めて
もうこのビルの人々は二月
これからもう十八日まで
このこのセクションからこのセクションまで綺麗にしなくちゃいけないんだ
それを地図も出したりすると楽しくないんです
ただそれだけで楽しみが消えちゃうんです
で 生きることも同じで
生きていきたいと思おうが
もう生きていきたくないと思おうが関係なく
脅迫的に我々は生きていなくちゃいけないんです
そういうシステムになっているんです
だからかなり楽しくはない
生きることは だったらあんた死にたいのかというと
ちょっと待ってくれということ
なんでとってもするかっていったっても
やっぱりあの終わりたくはないんですね
目的にも達してないんですね
そういうのは まあ輪廻の
まあシンプルで輪廻を見ると
そういう風に見えることなんです
物事をシンプルで考えるのは嫌ですから
なかなか真理は発見できないんですね
すごく複雑に考えたいんですね
それもまあ構いませんだけど
なぜならば そもそも思考能力がないんだから
どうせできるだけ複雑に考えてくださいということになりますけど
とにかく思考能力がある人っていうのは
物事はとても客観的に
単純でシンプルでシンプル
シンプルで見るんです
そうすると まあ人生はそういうものであるということはわかるんですね
あんまり証拠なんかも要りませんしね
証拠はあまりではなくて
全く要りません なぜならば自分自身だからね
自分自身の心を見ると
もうそこで自動的に実証されています
死にたいのかと自分に聞けば
私は死にたくない それで何か証拠はないのかと
意味がないでしょうね
私は他人に聞いて あんた死にたくないんですか？はい
死にたくない じゃあ証拠を出してみてください
なりたたないでしょう
だから実証ですよ 何か聖書みたいなものを持っていく必要はないんです
これ何ページも何行も参考にしてみてくださいとかね
そちらに書いてありますからとかね
だから人間について語る場合は
この聖書のもう何々本の何々章の何々行というのは
もうあんまりにもバカバカらしい
生きてるんだから みんなね
いいやそんなの そういう風に今本を持ってくること自体がもう真理はもう知らないということになります
ですから 生きるということはそういうことで
まず面白くないし 苦しいし
脅迫されて生きているし
できないのは皆様に脅迫されて生きているという気持ちも知ってるんです
喜んで生きてるわけじゃないっていうこと
どうしようもないんだから生きている
自分には自由がないんです
選択の自由はないんです
生きて生きているか生きていないかとかね
それはないんです 生きるしかないんです
だから選択もなく もうこれ決めなくちゃいけない
それは脅迫なんですね
しかし 人々に 無知な人々にね
思考能力ない人にできないのは
誰に脅迫されているのかっていうことね
誰って言ったら人ですけど
もう人でなくてもいいんです
何が脅迫になっているのかという
だから怖い怖い怖いと言って言ってるだけです
不安不安だと言ってるだけです
なんかすごい不安だとかね
あれやこれやと言ってますよ
それ以上はわからないんです
何が不安かもわからないし
なぜ不安なのかもわからないんです
何が怖いのかとものすごい厳しく聞くと
なんとかなんとか言いますけど
なぜかというとわからないんですね
だから怖いと恐怖感を感じていると
ではあなたを脅しているのは誰ですかと
何がですかと 何に脅されているのか
誰に脅されているのかというと
それはもう無知の世界になっちゃうんです
道の世界の無知じゃなくて
それが大変な残念なことで
それわかれば人生は楽しくなるんです
脅迫で生きてるんじゃなくて
自分好きで生きてれば楽しいでしょう
自分で転んで公園綺麗にしたってもね
楽しいだけなんです 言われてやるともう苦しいんですね
だからはっきり言えば楽しい
苦しいっていうこともおかしいんですよ
そんなに具体性がないんです
同じ公園の掃除なんですから
なんで自分好きでやるときは楽しくて
言われて決まって決まりでやるときは結構苦しいのかと
変でしょうにね 仕事量はまるっきり同じなのに
だから 人生は楽しいんだ
苦しいんだと言ってもね
あんまり意味のある言葉じゃないんです
まあいるでしょうね 私本当に苦しいんだ
生きることはと あなたなんかはね
そんなにもうニコニコ
笑って生きていたいもんだなとか
そんなこと言われたってどちらでも同じなんです
結局 誰も同じことをして生きているんでしょうに
そこで一人の人生が楽しくて
一人の人生が苦しくてっていうのはどういうことですか
だからこの公園の掃除で考えてください
成り立ちませんよ 苦しいか楽しいかっていうことさえも
論理的には だからそこは強迫観念なんですよ
だから強迫があるかないか
それだけ 人がご飯を食べていると
そちらに脅迫があるならば
すごい拷問とかね もうものすごくいじめられたことになるんです
脅迫なかったら楽しいんです
ご飯食べることにかっても
だから この本当に皆様方の誰でもシンプルで考えるならばありがたいんですが
このわかるんです その難しい論理
生命に対する 現代哲学者に
西洋の哲学者に 誰にも発見できなかったこのすごい真理が何のことなくわかるんですけど
はい はい それとこの輪廻ということをね
で 最悪になることも自分好きでやるんじゃなくて
好きか嫌いか関係ないんです
そうなるんです そちらも自由がないんです
死んだらまた再び何とかの形で現れなくちゃいけないんです
これ時間の感覚もないんです
壊れると同時に次のものができているんだからね
時間の隙間がないんです
例えばガラスは割れましたと
割れて分経ったらガラスの破片がもう現れたってことはありえないんですね
ガラスが割れる もう破片もある
破片というものは最悪なんです
そのガラスの破片はもう
またもう次の次のものね
リサイクルだったらそれはそれで
もうまた潰して粉にすれば
それそれでまたそこはもう温めればまた溶かしてまた同じガラスになったりもするし
同じものになりませんだけど
またなんとかまたガラス
またガラス一つ作ることも不可能ってわけじゃないんだけど
同じものにはなりませんね
それでも それはまた面白くないんですよ
割れた壺がまた壺になるならば
全然ありがたいことで
全然悲しいことじゃないんです
たとえ たとえ大きい壺が割れちゃったところで
ちょっとまあ 5 ミリぐらい小さい壺になりましたと
1 ミリぐらいの周りが小さくなって
それでもありがたいんでしょうね
まあ構いませんよということになりますけど
でも壺が割れたら壺にならないんですね
別なものになるんですね
我々は人間が死んだら同じにならないんですよ
だから私たちは 私の核は何なのかと
わかるわけないんです
それを知りたければ もう再生し
紙を見て それはもう日経新聞か読売新聞再生しかなんとかはっきりしてほしいんです
そんな具体的に触ることもできる
調べることもできる世界でも
後をたどることできないんですよ
そんな時間も経ってないでしょうに
で 子供たちのおもちゃっていうのは全部再生のプラスチックでしょ
全部 であれはどんなものを壊れたものを作ったんですかね
全くわからないんですね
だから輪廻っていうのは確実にあるんだけど
この頭ではね 全くわからないんです
それは次元論になります
知識次元というものあるんですよ
知識次元を破らないと三次元に限った知識では何一つも理解できません
だから三次元の知識であるポケットの中に入って閉じ込められているだけ
ポケット外はもう知ることはできないのです
だからこの 輪廻はこの我々の三次元的な思考で知ることはできない
あの物は再生 何か別なものをリサイクルして作っても
例えば科学者とかね そういう人々には
この原子調べたりする人々にとっては
もう原子にしたってもそれぞれバラバラだからね
もう似てないんですね
カーボンにしたっても
それぞれカーボンの自分の特色を持っているんです
だからもうこれはカーボンなんですけど
このカーボンはこういうこういうものに
ところによくあるものだとわかると
ああ もしかするとそちらのものが再生しているんだよとは言えます
それは科学者に研究者に言えるのであって
これにはかなり苦しくて
あらゆる調べをしなくちゃいけないんです
見てすぐ言ったってことじゃないんです
だから この物質の再生を言うためには
もうそれぐらい難しいんだからね
もう手に取れるのに 生命としての再生はなおさら難しいんですね
だから我々も何か微妙に持ってますよ
前のものは それは発見できるのかと
だから知識は次元をやっぱり超えないと
わからないです うん はい
それであの こういうポイントは説法として大事なところ
我々は生きているが 強迫の強迫的に生きているんだから
生きること自体も面白くない
苦しい しかし 死にたいのだったら死ねと言ったら
ちょっと待ってという気分になります
死にたくはないんだと
ということは この旅まだ終わってないんです
だから死んでもまた再生
再雨になっちゃうんです
これまた面白くないんです
壊れた壺の破片を粉にして
圧力かけて固めて あのタイルを作りましたと
どちらの方が面白いかと
壺の方が面白いんです
タイルの方がそれほど評価できませんね
なんかすごくちょっとレベル低い評価なんですね
ゴミを再生して まあ道路の皆歩くところにタイル作って貼っているんだと
なんてありがたい壺の再現でしょうかとかね
全然ないんですね だから我々死んでまた再生したっても同じ評価なんです
だからこれもまた悲しい苦しいことなんです
そこで再生することも脅迫なんですね
自分では判断できません
死んだら再び再生するしかないんです
これはもう隙間なく起こるんです
だからそちらにも自分の意思が働いてないんだから
自分で好んでやっているわけじゃないんだから
またそちらにも苦しいんです
再び現れた人々 現れた生命が
その生命で生きているのであって
いろんな不満があっても
何があったってもどうにもならぬんですね
次は次の仕事をするしかないんです
壺がタイルになったらタイルの仕事をするしかないんです
私は人に踏まれた身分ではなかったとかね
そんなこと今更言ってる場合じゃないんです
もう踏まれる身分になっちゃったんです
犬もその上にフンを出したりもする
壺でいた時よりも何もないんですよ
それで再生した生命 再生することも嫌なもんで脅迫的だからね
そうすると新しいシステムに従ってしっかり従って生きているしかないんですね
そちらはまた自分で好んでやっていることではなくなってしまっちゃって
言われてやる羽目になって
これまた苦しいんですね
それでもあなたどうですか
今更今 2回目だから死んだらいかがですかと
これはないんですね 旅も終わってないんです
それはまたさらに苦しいんですね
それが輪廻の本当の要求なんですね
どんな側面から見ても
もう納得いかない 気に入らない
喜べない 満足感を感じないものになっているんです
で それまた人間無知だから何かそれだったら何か喜びを感じる何かあるのかとまた探すんですね
これまたおかしい で そのために公園の話を出したんです
おかしいんです 公園の掃除することと同じなんです
一人が楽しいし 一人が苦しいんだけど
仕事量は同じなんです
だから幸福に楽しみに対する我々の考えもまた間違っているんです
だから探しても見つかりっこはないんです
ということは どうしても智慧を開拓しなくちゃいけないんです
無知でいて 信仰でいて
決して達することは 発見することはできないんです
そこでもしある人がこの旅を終わったならば
もう表現できんほど無量無限の安らぎを感じているはずなんです
旅が終わりました 明日まで
明日まで生きてきて 明日そんなことはないんだと
あと 10分で死んだらもう大丈夫ですよと言うんです
もう先やることはないんだと
全部終わりました だからその人こそ究極の極限の幸福
安らぎ 平安というのを味わっているんです
それは我々思っている苦に対する楽じゃないんです
次元超えてるんです ですから
人間であろうが神々であろうか
すべての生命の理解次元は超えているんです
我々人間の世界で言ったっても
やっぱり苦も楽も存在しないと見えるでしょうに
ご飯食べること楽しいでしょうか
言ったっても 誰か今ご飯食べなさいと言われたら美味しく楽しくないんです
これこれ食べなさいと
全然楽しくないんです
自分の たとえ好物であっても
命令されるとまずくなるんです
だから私たち知ってる世界から見ても
なんかおかしいんですよ
だから心のこの持ち方というかね
ただそれだけなんです
どう見るのかっていう
次元は関係ないんです
外の世界 どうでもいい
そのままいい そのままなんです
だって心のアプローチで言えばいろんなアプローチできるんだから
それまた当てにならないんです
明るいアプローチで生きてみようとかね
どうでもいい そんなのは
次勝手に変えられますからね
明るいアプローチもできるし
暗いアプローチもできるし
嫌なアプローチもできるし
悲観的なアプローチもできるし
破壊的なアプローチ何でもできますからね
だから仏教の方はアプローチ全部取り消す
それがもうまた次元を超えた世界
アプローチがある限りはもう知ってる世界のことです
我々には三次元に閉じ込まれてるんだから
どんなアプローチを組んだって全部三次元の中のアプローチですからね
どうったことないんです
泥の汚いものの中に生きているウジ虫は
どんなに哲学思想を作っても
すべてあのおむつの中の話です
花に染みて公園に染みては
ウジ虫には哲学はできません
だからそんなのは全然当てにならないんです
人間がどんな立派な思考を作ったっても
ウジ虫の人生論と同じなんです
自分生きてる範囲の中でいろいろいろいろやってるだけで
じゃ 世界にあるすべての哲学やら宗教の本やら全部調べてみても
この理想的な境地って何なのかと
何もないでしょう ただ
人間の世界のこと あっちこっちでレゴで入れ替えたりするような感じで
何か考えてるだけ それも観念的で
レゴを組み立てたらこんなものになるんじゃないか
でも実際は組み立てられない
そういうふうなものは
はい そういうことで このガタッでの旅を終わったという言葉は
その意味なんです この旅が終わったと
これ並大抵のこと言ってるんじゃない
大変なことを言ってるんです
で 次はもう自然にもうただもう加えて語ってるので
ガタッでもだけで全部語れています
ヴィソーカッサっていうのはもう上はないんだと
悩みはないんだ 悲しくはない
悲しみ終わりましたと
終わってるでしょうに
もうもう脅迫的に生きたいってことがもう終わったんだから
もう だから何に悲しむんです
悲しみもうないんです
だから 俗世間的に言えば
悲しみっていうのは必然的にあるんですね
だから公園を掃除しなさいって言ってるんだからね
だから嫌っていうことはもう必然的に結びついてるんです
我々一人一人何時生きなさいと言われているんだから
生きることは 1 秒  1 秒単位で必然的に悩み
悲しみと合体しているんです
離れません 楽しく生きるっていうことは成り立たないんです
悲しく生きるんです それで旅を終わった人ね
それないんですからね
もう で次 このヴィッパムッダッササッバで全ての物事からもう自由になりましたっていうことはね
で これ義務が終わったっていうことですね
今肉体持ってるんだから
義務ありすぎ それでも皆様思っている義務ではなくて
そんなのはどうでもいいんだけど
もっと大変な義務がある
一つ呼吸しなくちゃいけないんですよ
そういうのは本物の義務なんです
ちょっと試しに 一休みできますかね
かなり脅迫されてますよ
恐ろしく ちょっと 1 分
2 分ぐらい呼吸を止めていたら
まああの脅迫は並みじゃないでしょうね
本当に殺されますから
物の見事に だからそれは何で感じないんです？私は恐ろしく脅迫されているんだから
呼吸してるんです ご飯食べることも同じことなんです
パーティーやるもんじゃないんです
もうどこまで無知かというと
この楽しいことじゃないんです
コックさんになったり
あの料理 この料理とか
フランス料理 中華料理とか
何が悪いと もう恐ろしくもう脅迫されて義務で義理でやってるんですよ
もうやめられませんね
そういうことで 1 秒も休みないんです
私たちは やるべきことはいっぱいあるんです
その上なんですね 学校に行かなくちゃとか
仕事に行かなくちゃとか
そんなのはこれと比較するとどうったことないんです
子供と旦那の服にアイロンかけなくちゃとか
そんな程度のことです
本当に大変ですね お坊さんの生きていることとかね
悟りたい時 いい加減にしろよと
悟れませんよと また  [笑い]旦那と子供の服がたくさんなってアイロンかけるのが大変やと
そんな程度の人生の苦労が上がってきたってもね
もう冗談の言いところですよ
おかしなことはそういうことはやめることもできます
だからそんなに本来的な義務じゃないんです
子供を育てなくちゃとか
どこかに捨てていっちゃえばいいでしょうに
できるでしょ だからやめることができる義務っていうのは
誰が義務と言うんですかね
できればやめられますよと
それは義務じゃないんです
一つに じゃあ呼吸に際して
あんたもできればやめても構いませんよと
オプションだと オプションじゃないんです
我々は一般人のというか
仏陀 お釈迦様への愚か者ですからね
その人々はもう義務で義理とことで結婚することやら
子育てことやら 仕事をすることやら
そんなものなんです あの全てオプションなんです
やめられます だからですよ
ブッダの教えをわかった人々は出家したのは
オプションだからなんです
いくら結婚して赤ちゃんも生まれたばっかしで
それでも別れますよ 赤ちゃんが生まれてまだ 1ヶ月も経ってないんだから
私出家したいんだけど
まあ子供が小学校に上がるまでちょっと待ってくれませんかと
今は無理やと言ってもね
本当はオプションです
お釈迦様は生まれたその日で出家したんです
子供が それは日本の人々はね
大変な残酷なことをしましたとかね
誰に向かって言ってるんですかね
何を知って言ってるんですかね
だから義務っていうのは
俗世間はオプションの義務じゃないでオプションだからね
義務っていうのは生きることなんですね
俺が一秒も休めないんです
すっげえ脅迫されているんです
それで全てから離れたということは
家族はなく 出家したんだ程度のことじゃないんです
家族を置いて出家しましたとかね
もう金持ちでしたけど
もう金は全部はいさようならと言って出家してまったということではないんですね
別な出家があるんです
生きること そこから全部もうバイバイ
さようならしなくてもいいんだよということ
なっちゃったんです 間違った言葉で言えば
呼吸呼吸しなくてもいいということになったことになりますけど
ではその意味ではないんです
どうしても生きていけ
生きていなくてはいけないという義務が消えちゃったんです
だから それはすごい俗っぽく言えば
呼吸しなくてもよろしいやと
ご飯食べなくてもよろしいということになったようなことですけど
でもそんな意味ではなくないんですけどね
だから一切の義務から解放されたら
これすごい楽なんです
会社の社長がね 会社の責任全部自分を背負っていて
会社はもう例えばね アメリカか日本の会社でも始めた時からもう倒産するまで悪いこと以外何もやってないと
違法的なこと以外何もやってないと
時々一部だけ取ってさばいたりもするし
で そうなってくると全責任社長は背負わなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでまた同じオルシで
もうその問題としては
まぁ社長は問わないんだと
関係ないことになるんだと
言うと楽なんです で 最近の例え話で言えば
あの郵便会社の社長があらゆる不正的なことをして
まぁ未だに国民の財産ですけど
やりたい放題いろんなことをやって
で 不正的なことをして
まぁあなたは責任取らなくちゃあかんでしょうと言ったら
あれ違いますよと 言ったら何の関係もなく
これ国民のものはしっかりやりましょうと言ったあなたが悪いんだと
いうことで大臣は更迭になると
悪いことをした人は堂々と
ほら 見てみろよという調子で
で 国民の代表である大臣にさえも力がないんだと
これ個人の方がもっと偉いということになると
もうその人は楽でしょうね
今喜んでウイスキーでも飲んでるでしょうね
あの鳩山さんがもう私はそんなもんやと
たとえ政府でも跪くようにするぞと
そういうことで あの 例えば会社の社長が何か責任持たなくちゃいかない
例えばもう脱税があったりとかね
資料を誤魔化したりとかね
もう品物のラベル入れ替えたりとかね
まぁいろんなことをして
それは次から次へとバレてバレてバレてバレて
もう国際的にも犯罪人になったりとかね
国内的にも犯罪者になったりとか
まだ払わなくちゃ もう自分も個人的にも
もう百億 二百億とか もう払わなくちゃいけないとか
しかしそれにまた罰金も加算されるとか
そうなってくるとかなり重い負担がね
それで誰かが大丈夫 まぁこういう法律でこういうことできますから
あなたは何の関係もないことになりますよと言われたらどれほど楽しいかというと
すいませんよと 日本の警視庁
警視庁と同じく 自分たちが個人的に気に入らない人を裁くんです
できますよ 皆さんみんな同じことやってますから
あいつは気に入らない
はい 明日逮捕ということになる
はい そのヴィパッササーサッダディっていうのは
あの そういう俗っぽい話じゃなくて
あの くだらん話でもなくて
あの 生きるということでは
我々は果たさなくちゃいけない義務
無数にあるんですね それにすごく苦しいんですね
それからもういいよということになるんです
はい それはちょっと人間にとってはね
あのちょっと理解できないんだからね
まあ別で簡単な解説はしてはあると思います
はい 次の言葉はサッバガンタッパヒーナッス
このガンタっていうのはこの結び目のことなんです
あるいはあの引っかかるんですね
あるフックみたいな感じで
引っかかっちゃうんですね
だから我々はいくつかのフックで輪廻に引っかかってるんです
輪廻したくないと言ってられる場合じゃないんです
するしかないんです 苦しくは生きて生きたくはないと言ってる場合じゃないんです
苦しみなさいってことなんです
だから義務が生じるんですよ
例えば犬を飼うと 飼ったらもうずっと義務が生じているんです
もう逃げられません 飼った時点でもうあの犬が遊んで遊んでいて
誰かちょっと噛んで怪我でもさせたら全責任自分自分で負わなくちゃいけないんです
で あんた犬と遊んだんだからあんた悪いでしょみたいな話は通じません
人の犬を頭ちょっと可愛い可愛いと触ろうと思ったところに犬がパクっと噛んだったならば
飼い主が弁償しないといけない
でも犬が何かやったらこちらの責任で犬が病気になったらこちらの責任で
犬の毛が落ちるようになったらこちらの責任で
で ああいう風にもうかなり束縛されます
1週間ぐらいどこかで行きたいのに
もう向こうも来てください来てくださいと言ってるのに
自分も行きたいし 犬を飼ってるんだからね
もうどこにも行けなくなっちゃうと
はい そこでこのフックは何ですかね
なんでそれぐらい仕事ついてきたんですかね
犬は可愛いと思ったってことでしょ
ああ 可愛い 飼いたいなと
それにやられちゃったんです
犬は本当に可愛いんですよとかね
だからこの子私は買っちゃったと
はい 可愛いということで
あれがフックなんですね
そのフックでものすごい大量の苦しみが引っかかってきたんです
釣り針みたいなもんですかね
まあ悪くはないんだけど
その例えば自分が食ってるんだからね
まあこちらは逆ですからね
自分がフックを持っていって苦しみに引っかかっ引っかかってるんですね
自分がええもんです 苦しむのは
注釈書は今日入れてないな
必要なところ この眼帯フークはこのつあるんです
注釈書では書いてないんだから
この書いてるテキストはないかどうかね
見つけたってなれば まあ難しいんですから
説明するのは うーん ミャンマーの本でおそらく書いてると思います
ちょっとこの人 ミャンマーの本
おそらく一人しか書いてないのは普通ですけどね
書いてないね それはミャンマー好みじゃないんです
経典の内容を説明するのは
この輪廻に束縛 束縛されている
このフークというものはね
フークはね あのちょっと言葉をちょっと変えて使ってカーヤ眼帯と言うんですね
あのカーヤっていうのは体ということではなくて
仏教では意味は体なんですけど
あの 組織に対して言ってるシステム
輪廻というシステムにもうシステムをせなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから こののところで引っかかっているんだと
で で 言葉を変えると微妙にいろんなところで変わってしまいますからね
内容は えーと  1番目は誰でも知ってるアヴィッジャ
あのー アヴィッジャっていうのは異常な欲望
うーん ちょっと理屈くずれて論理的でないところでも欲が生まれてくる
これいつにありますよ
我々の欲はいつでもすごく論理的で
あのー すごく常識で当たり前っていうことじゃないんです
例えばすごく喉が渇いて乾いたら水を飲みたくなりますよ
それはものすごい論理的で具体的で
別にどうってことないんです
水を飲みたいなっていうことは
我々はその程度の欲ですかね
持っているのは 喉が渇いてるんだから
水が水に対して欲がありますよ
それでもう今喉が渇いてないんだから
全然欲がないんだという程度ですかね
我々の生き方は だから我々の欲っていうものは
見れば見るほど全部アヴィッジャで異常欲なんです
だから心にこの異常欲が入っているんです
異常欲だから叶うっていうこともほぼないんです
異常でない欲は叶うん
叶うんですよ 異常はもう
まあ例えば生活保護とか
日本の政府から まあケチなんですけど
まあそれでもあのいくらかね
まあ万とか万程度とかくれたりはするな
いくら何回かとかね そこで何もない人がお願いしますと
あの万ではなく 私はあの一緒にテレビも買いたいんだけど
新しい 古いテレビあったんだけど
あれはもう見えませんだからね
で だからあのテレビ 1台値段見ましたけど
あの万になりますよと
だから万もちょうだいと
そしたらくれる？区役所から
よくわかりました はい
万プラス万で はい あなた持っていってくださいと
だから異常欲はもう叶わないんですよ
人間が死んだら困りますから
やっぱりこの日本の政府であっても
いくらかくれるんです
そこはもう政府ありがたいではなくて
異常欲じゃないんですよ
人間ならやっぱり何か食べて生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
どこかに住まなくちゃいけないんですね
それは異常欲じゃないんです
それもない場合はもう政府でもあげるんです
しかし 私たちの期待 希望って一つもやってくれないでしょ？誰も
というわけ ということは
全て異常欲なんです 異常欲は叶わないんです
だからみんなもう常に生きることは激しく苦しいなのに
義務がやりきれんほど抱えているのに
あのオプションの義務にも足が引っ張られて
その上この異常な欲を何とかして自分のものにしてやるぞと
もう苦しく苦しんでるんです
すっと頭いかれてるんですよ
服にしたっても 有名ブランドでなければあきませんとかね
今度のパリコレの物でなければ
パリコレのあれでなければいけませんとかね
カバンはこのメーカーでなければとかね
住んでるところは東京からもう三十分で電車で行ったり来たりできるところでなければダメとかね
それも公園のそばでなければいけませんとかね
だからそのためには もうそんなところでも一応マンションとかありますよ
六本木なんとかヒルズとかもあるし
もうすごく高級マンションもね
もうもう四十階六十階まで作ってありますけど
でも 何て言いますか 家賃はね
月々大体二百五十万 三百万ですね
あの 本当に生活しやすいマンションできてます
あの 一応外国基準で 標準で
で 家具も全部揃ってあって
全部高級家具で  お客さんが来たっても
ちゃんと別室に生活できるように
まあそのもうトイレやら全部用意して
そういうあのビジターズルームまであって
で よくできてますよ まあ住みたいんだけどね
誰が払いますかね 月々
月々二百万 二百万では終わらないです
あれは家賃だけだからね
ということで もし私がどうしてもそっちのところに住みたいと思うと
どこまで苦労したら済むもんですかね